Don't worry, my life is not in danger,...
...and I'm not competing for money.
I'm just playing a game I grew up with called "ppopgi."
Chisel the shape out of the candy without it breaking,...
...and thanks to the Netflix hit, Squid Game,,...
...the rest of the world is playing ppopgi too,...
...from Peru to Indonesia, even making an appearance on Saturday Night Live.
Broke my cookie, and I got eliminated.
The sugar candy called "dalgona" even becoming an obsession on TikTok.
Will I survive the dalgona game?
Guess not!
Squid Game tells the story of 456 down on their luck contestants...
...playing childhood games in the hopes of winning millions.
In the third episode, players have to try this candy challenge.
There's the easy shapes like the triangle to the tricky umbrella,...
...but the stakes here are much higher.
Any breakage and...
I got it!
Now, for the taste test.
It's bitter, nutty, sweet,...
...brings back that old taste that I remember from when I was a kid.
So, what makes this dalgona street candy stand in Seoul so special?
Remember this?
This shop actually made about 700 of these...
...and sold it to the filmmakers of Squid Game, and there are so many people in line.
The shop also sells the candy in the tins seen in the show...
...along with all the shapes, even one shaped like the "Red light, green light" doll.